the problem is we didn't try it and
fettered free market capitalism because
sure we're now talking about explicitly
naming all these firms too big to fail
but the reality of the system has been
that these firms were already implicitly
too big to fail hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with reason TV today I'm talking to
Anthony Randazzo a policy analyst at
Reason Foundation and author of the new
policy brief storming Wall Street about
plans to regulate the financial industry
thanks for talking Anthony thanks for
having me there are three bills on tap
for discussion and possible passage in
mid-september what are they you've got
first the Consumer Financial Protection
Agency bill which is essentially a bill
to try and create a single agency that
will take all the consumer protection
regulation roles from the other agencies
put it in under one roof on this is
mortgages credit cards credit cards more
days yeah any any sort of financial
product any innovation whether it's from
a bank or a non-bank would all be housed
in this agency and this agency would
have the power to create its own sort of
standardized products simple plain
vanillas what they use products and
force all companies to actually offer
these in addition to theirs right and
then their argument there is that they
want contracts for credit cards or loans
or whatever that people can read in four
minutes or less yeah that ends all
simple very simplified right of course
the bill that they're creating is not
readable by any Americans and it's not
readable format to last but what is
what's wrong with that bill the the
biggest problem with that bill is that
it is telling companies what they can
and cannot do in terms of operating it's
saying you are going to you can't offer
this product because it's too complex or
if you're going to offer this product
you have to write it in this language
and in some cases they're going to say
here's a product and you have to offer
this you have to offer this type of
mortgage whether or not it's profitable
to that Bank because we feel that it's
simple enough that this is what most
people are going to want so does that
raise
in the way that if you say to walmart or
a sears roebuck or kmart or whatever you
have to care you can carry whatever you
want but you also have to carry this
line of good yes exactly what it is
what's the the next bill on time the
next one is sort of a broad approach to
regulating derivatives financial
products themselves you've got the
consumer side but then you've got a
separate bill which may it may wind up
being coupled with this so they pass
these together but this is actually
talking about whether or not it's even
right to be creating credit default
swaps and so you've got the you know how
like how we going to protect consumers
and then we've got like whether or not
banks can even be allowed to compete in
creating these things what very quickly
defined as simply as possible to credit
default swap and what role did they play
in the financial crisis very simply a
credit default swap is insurance it's
insurance on another trader or something
else and it's can be offered by a
company like AIG and so AIG offered all
these credit default swaps on different
trades for different companies like
Goldman Sachs or bear stearns AIG going
down and credit default swaps sort of
becoming unstable it absolutely was a
problem for the different companies but
if you if you look at it through a sort
of free market perspective these
companies were depending on a company
that maybe wasn't that great which means
they weren't making good decisions they
didn't have good business models and
protecting those companies that have bad
business models probably not a great
idea but this is the too-big-to-fail
theory right which is that once you get
to a certain size you don't have to be
that kind of a conscious of your
business model because as long as you're
big enough we know that you're never
actually going to fall exactly which is
actually the third sort of bill that
they're putting out which that's the big
one and this is what's probably going to
be brought up in October is this bill to
regulate systemic risk so they're going
to create this tiered system where all
banks big banks all non-bank financial
institutions like hedge funds even big
insurance companies
they're all if their determines too big
to fail they're going to be called a
tier 1 risk to your one financial
holding company and they're gonna be put
in this top slot and all those companies
if anything bad happens to them
government steps in to save them and
they'll know it one of the arguments is
you know we tried unregulated free
market capitalism unfettered buying and
selling and greed and look where we are
now so this is a you know just a simple
response saying like if you're that big
you've got to pay more attention to what
you're doing well the problem is is we
didn't try unfettered free market
capitalism because sure we're now
talking about explicitly naming all
these firms too big to fail but the
reality of the system has been that
these firms were already implicitly too
big to fail if you just go back and you
look at minutes of meetings and the
Federal Reserve where they got bank
presidents together in the midst of the
financial crisis Lehman Brothers was
astounded that they didn't get saved you
listen to their leaders talk to guys
Nura bernanke they were stunned that
they were let failed they assumed that
like Bear Stearns like long-term capital
management back in the day that they
were too big to fail what is more
difficult for the investment climate or
for the financial system is it knowing
that you're going to be regulated
harshly and inefficiently or you're not
even sure whether or not the regulations
are going to be stable over time
ultimately banks can get around any type
of regulation so while we're going to
sit back and talk about the different of
different problems with the different
reforms uncertainty really is the
biggest problem and so there's the
argument by many that we just need to
get reform over with now we need to get
this through as soon as possible because
a bank can figure out how to operate in
any so given a given up said regulatory
regime that is certain is better than a
good one that is uncertain a bet on the
margin right so I mean if it's too bad
yes but but banks can sometimes even use
that as sort of a competitive advantage
in terms of okay so we're having all
these different products limited in what
we're offering what can we offer that's
better than the next company is given
that they're in the same sort of climate
so you do have that but what we are
talking about is we're talking about
directing their ability to create wealth
and so a bad regulatory regime may get
cut mate it may be better than
uncertainty and make companies going but
it means we're going to have the economy
recovering slower and it's not going to
recover as strong as it could if we were
to reform the market in such a way that
we allow companies to grow much much
faster much wider our big companies now
are they leaning towards massive
regulation because they know they will
have both the political and economic
resources to kind of screw over the
scrappy or innovators who are going to
bring the next level of new ways of
doing business in a lot of ways yes yes
they are theirs in some ways there are
members of the industry that are going
to wind up being okay with these
regulations because they have in some
sense that's regulatory capture they're
able to say well yeah we've got these
problems but all the other big guys have
the same problems and no one's else get
no one's going to really step up but no
CEO in the right mind really wants these
regulations they may be able to can see
well this is you know what's politically
this is the reality and this is what
we're going to accept no CEO in the
right mind wants did not be allowed to
offer certain derivative products so I
mean yeah and a lot of ways we're
talking about things on the margins
we're talking about what could be or
what couldn't be financial services
reform whatever happens is probably not
going to be the end of the world but it
is important in terms of America really
being fiscally financially stable moving
down the road and whatever happens it
will push back any kind of recovery but
some some momentum yeah I mean you're
going to have on for like unseen
unintended consequences we may not know
how far it may push back recovery we're
never going to know what kind of recover
we could have seen if we restrict these
companies ability to produce wealth it's
it's going to do something thank you
very much today we were talking with
Anthony Randazzo a policy analyst at
Reason Foundation and author of the new
policy briefs storming Wall Street for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie